we have a tradition here because we take
a very serious responsibility that we
inform these people we are our news show
yes uh
and so we're gonna be off for a couple
of months you're where i get all my news
exactly i know you do and i appreciate
that homie
we do future headlines this is the
headlines that are going to happen see
we we're not going to be here but we
still
that's our crack staff is so good they
can tell you would you like to see some
of the future headlines we have
uh these are things that we know are
gonna happen
uh
britney spears found nude in lion
enclosure that is definitely
[Laughter]
a jeopardy host dumped over newly
discovered problematic preschool artwork
uh racist karen calls 9-1-1 on anti-mass
karen cop karen shows up and shoots both
oh
inevitable happening
putin critic survives fall from building
by landing on previous putin critic who
fell from war
fox news gives confederate flag its own
show
an ultimate troll move biden changed his
name to brandon
leaked facebook memo admits the
metaverse is just going to be guys
jerking off
[Applause]
now
meghan markle to accept bitcoin for
whatever it is she does
bristol palin announces engagement to
kyle rittenhouse
that is
inevitable
and town that voted to defund the police
wakes up to find everything gone
[Applause]
you